victoria brown co-founder big think i am
originally from toronto and i actually
don't think that it shaped me too much i
think my parents shaped me more than
where i'm from my parents are one is
irish one is American and so we were
always none of us were Canadians growing
up in Canada and so we're always were a
little bit of outsiders and so we kind
of have that mentality i think i'm not
really sure my my family is pretty
creative and both my siblings are actors
and my sister is also a writer so it's
kind of been in the blood and i knew i
wanted to do it from you know a long
time it was just a question of having
the courage to kind of go and move to LA
and start as an unpaid intern and a
waitress and that type of thing so I
mean that I've just kind of known that I
wanted to do it I can't think of this
precise event that told me this is what
you will do
um well you know what it was sort of not
about business I wanted to do something
entrepreneurial and I had wanted to work
in the entertainment and media field and
so after I graduated from university I
moved to France for a year and while I
was there I decided you know I'm really
interested in film and television and
that type of thing so I moved back to
Toronto very briefly before moving to
Los Angeles to work in film and so while
I was there I thought you know I don't
really want want to work my way up the
studio system I'd actually like to be
running things and creating things and
having creative say and what I'm doing
and so I realized that all too often
creative people don't really understand
that what they're doing is also a
business and so they kind of need to be
trained in that way to operate on the
same level as the business people and so
I figured I better get some training in
business and so went to business school
but it wasn't because I really wanted to
be a business person it's just that I
wanted to understand what business
people did so that I could participate
you